نشير مجددا الى ان قوات الاحتلال تواصل
محاصره مبنى تابع للهلال الاحمر في جباليه
بداخله مسعفون وجرحى ومعنا من شمالي غزه
احمد الكحلوت مدير الدفاع المدني في شمال
غزه اهلا بك معنا هل لديكم اي معلومات حول
وضع المحاصرين في هذا
المبنى صحيح لا تزال الاوضاع الكارثيه
والصعبه جدا في شمال غزه على حالها نحن
ايضا طواقم الدفاع المدني وطواقم اسعاف
وتوق الاحمر بتنا محاصرين في منطقه مخيم
جباليا ومدينه جباليا لا يستطيع طواقم
الدفاع المدني وطواقم المقدمين الخدمات
الاسعافيه التحرك ما بين مخيم جباليا
ومدينه جباليا
البلد الحركه صعبه جدا وخطيره جدا ولا
نستطيع الوصول الى يعني تردنا العديد من
الاشارات بمنطقه جبل البلد لدينا العديد
من الاشارات عن وجود شهداء ووجود اصابات
ملقاه على الارض في الشوارع لا نستطيع
الوصول اليها بتنا محاصرين ما بين مخيم
جباليا وجباليا البلد اي لا نستطيع الوصول
الى جبال البلد من منطقه الجرن ولا يوجد
اي نقطه تقدم الخدمات الطبيه النقطه
الوحيده التي كانت موجوده في جبل البلد تم
اخلائها بسبب القصف واستمرار القصف على
منطقه جبل البلد لم يتوقف القصف دقيقه
واحده منذ اكثر من 72 ساعه على مخيم
جباليا وجبالي البلد قصف مستمر من طرات
الا 16 وقصف مستمر ايضا من قضائ في
المدفعيه حيث تم فصل المخيم مخيم جبالي عن
منطقه جبال البلد لا نستطيع الوصول الى
العديد من الاشارات التي تردنا حتى سي على
الاقدام حاولنا منذ بالامس حاولنا الوصول
مع الطواقم المتواجده معي سيرا على
الاقدام الوصول الى منطقه دوار الحلبي تم
اطلاق النار علينا وتم استهداف الطواقم
واطلاق النار عليهم لا يمكن التحر فييها
المنطقه ولا يمكن التحرك ما بين جباليا
وجبال البلد ما الهدف في اعتقادكم من هذا
الحصار وهذا المنع لطواقم الدفاع المدني
من التنقل في هذه
المنطقه التنقل صعب جدا يعني بالكاد
بالكاد نسير في منطقه ضيقه جدا شارع اللي
هو شارع النادي المنطقه كلها
محاصره الاحتلال يطوق المخيم منطقه جبال
البلد منطقه اللي الشرق جبال البلد منطقه
شرق السكه لا نستطيع الوصول اليها منطقه
الفلوجه في غرب مخيم جباليا لا نستطيع
الوصول اليها ايضا كذلك شارع الجرن ومنطقه
الجرن في جنوب مخيم جباليا لا نستطيع
الوصول اليه يعني كيف تنظرون الى الس الى
الهدف في اعتقادكم لماذا لماذا تقوم قوات
الاحتلال ب محاصره طواقم الدفاع وعرقله
وصولها الى الجرحه
الاحتلال الاحتلال لا يزال يمعن في اجرامه
وفي قتله الاحتلال يعلم ان هناك العديد من
المصابين والعديد من الاحياء تحت الانقاذ
والذين يجب ان نصل اليهم لانقاذهم ولكنه
يمنع لمعان في القتل والمعان في الاجرام
في حق شعبنا والاستمرار في هذه الجريمه
البشعه المستمره منذ اكثر من 70 يوما شكرا
لك كنت
معنا من شمال غزه احمد الكحلوت مدير
الدفاع المدني في شمال غزه